[Music]
in BFF to stepmom news I just heard
about this book I saw this picture
submitted by Nelson Portillo what
support D our CEO a 27 year old married
her best friend's dad I was trying to
get that process down 27 year old very
only thing unusual about that is that's
their best friends right I mean that
happens all the time with young that is
very unusual is he rich
it's love David I don't believe in that
[ __ ] it's love
what's what's love got to do with
because it's not like that
if you know so Taylor she's 27
she's married current who's 54 years old
Kern yeah they met about five years ago
at his daughter's party in Phoenix
Arizona through her best friend named
Amanda who's 30 years old
Amanda oh my god that is younger
yeah mom's younger who's who so this is
a stepmom this is a daughter
oh damn she does look older yeah and so
they really lookin old man yeah is it
good looking out man been married for
about a year has a sad bellybutton
though
just frowning pretty bad though bro she
is bad as Mike yeah you gotta keep girls
like that away from your dad yeah
somebody's super important the [ __ ]
change a lot he doesn't like the same
people compare them to captors easy to
Joan and Michael Douglas she looks way
younger than Michael Douglas yeah she's
like Kevin Kern's wait go back to the
picture she does kind of like Kathryn a
little bit I mean if she wasn't the best
friend this is not weird true 54 year
old with a 30 year old or 27 I mean but
is he shady for doing that like you know
like hooking up with his daughters why
cuz the food the food landed on his lap
like well okay it depends on how it went
down right like did they ask her for
approval like you know what I mean or
did they do it behind her back
what if you're like really in love you
know what I mean like do you ask for
approval we'll see the thing is that
they both started off as like a rebound
thing because she had gotten out of
relationship he just got divorced and so
there were fuck-buddies first oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is there they were like
yeah we never thought that it would go
with this
I just divorced her mom but no - what if
it's another mom yeah and so they're
saying like in the beginning with Amanda
like it was really rocky that whole
relationship because I'd be pissed there
would best fit for a year like let's say
to me Oh wasn't like childhood best
friend and I don't know about that oh
wait what better friend I guess it's not
it's not real best friends I mean I'd
still be pissed off cuz I'd be like if
I'm your [ __ ] best friend you need to
talk to me 12 your old best friend [ __ ]
dude one year grown [ __ ] woman and
you meet someone for one year and you
call her your best friend I don't know
how that I don't know that that doesn't
work for me I know what but a lot of
girls do that though but for me like you
don't get the title of best friend
unless you've known them for like five
years plus or like you've grown up with
them or like you know me that's my best
friend rule though
well that's yours well you guys known
each other for five years but we've been
calling each other best friends brews
and and it's also it's also best work
the other daily let her speak let her
speak - and best friend is used it is a
twelfth like a 12 year old term but it's
it's the type of relationship and
closeness and openness that you have
with that particular person yeah
do you know what I mean so I could have
been but I I've had so many friends but
then it's like am i that open to like
with them was like that tight then I got
a lot of best friends I wish their girls
are a little bit more loosely the term
best friend Oh girls are far more loose
at the term best friend they're so like
[ __ ] with the best friend stay that's
it and don't hate each other like in a
weekend know like guys don't really be
like best friend your best friend but
that guy's nature it's not a guy's
nature to be as affectionate and as
tight as females are that's my point
no we're even more we're even more
effective because we have a special term
called best friend brother and friend
what nothing long I got a best friend
I'll say I call him a best friend you
know we call each other best who's your
best friend wreck Rex my best but I felt
kind of cook on the other side like it
do this full rectus right just hard it
right now I don't know he what when I
hear this term like for example I'd go
to jail for a couple months for Jo right
if I got a sentencing if it's gotta be a
year about yo job we got worked
something out a couple months for sure
I'll do it right would these people
after meeting each other for 12 months
would they go to jail for each I think
the difference is loyalty yes so like
the way guy see best friend learn at
least the way I see it is like time
loyalty commitment you know it's it's
more like a family member right versus
like I don't know in this way is it just
like oh we bond really well we tell each
other everything so then we're best
friends we both like doggy style
probably she's using best friend dogs
like we're really we hang out a lot work
clothes are or this is a wild idea maybe
it's [ __ ] click B maybe they don't
call each other best friend maybe
they're not all articles are honest
that's true I thought that was her words
but we also cause we weren't heard of
her words oh well so got best friends
that like you know we grew up with but
you know that we don't see them at all
they're not my best friend anymore or
the lot so they lost their best friend I
took that title with my [ __ ] the
best friend I grew up with he's like the
oldest friend I have had would you go to
jail I still call the best friend would
you go to jail I wouldn't go to jail for
most of my best friends because they're
very jail prone why the [ __ ] would I go
to jail for them like they should go to
jail if they need to go today sometimes
sometimes [ __ ] happens if he goes you're
bout to go right out for me you go to
jail for me yeah take a bullet did he
like if I kill myself my homie go kill
himself I will be there for him when
he's in jail you know Sam but like I
don't understand why would I be going to
jail forever it's a third strike thing
right so like if you are a criminal and
you've already got two strikes you know
and in the third strike you can't do it
I'll take the crime for you that's what
the that's what the whole all goes well
cause it's like less both of us were
there and I'll just put my finger prints
on ya 100% real my best friend goes to
[ __ ] in jail I'm sending him a couple
letters I'll see him like every light in
the first month a lot right but the
second month I'll start disappearing
like there's a little boy really [ __ ]
not even here for me ever and then when
you come out I'm gonna do a YouTube
video about it about my best friend
coming out of jail
exactly and then I was cry in front of
it that's that's that's honest Dave
right there right that is honest as it
gets
I mean I mean the truth is it's like
your relationships do change you know
I'm saying like yeah I don't know I
don't expect like the way I say that
sounds like cruel but what I mean by
that is like I don't expect them to do
that for me to in a way you know what I
mean like I don't I don't want them to
you know I wouldn't want them to they
take a selfishness like you know I mean
like I know some Street [ __ ] for sure
like then to reign you that's the street
as [ __ ] I don't expect y'all to do it
no but like for example let's say
someone comes over beats the [ __ ] out of
tiger rapes the [ __ ] out of you and then
Joe comes and kills that [ __ ]
right and he goes [ __ ] I'm out I gotta
go to Mexico and now they're looking for
the person that beat the [ __ ] out of
person I just raped you and beat the
[ __ ] out of tag on my [ __ ] I'm gonna
submit to it and I went to jail for Joe
and you're also Liam Neeson in this
fetishism
[Laughter]
you would be the better one to go cuz I
think you'll survive a little bit longer
than me
here's some more photos of the couple
yeah she's a 50 year old dizzy all right
she looks like [ __ ] for 27 27 year olds
but she looks old dirt she did another
27 she's not twenties what a suit were
like this is a this is a good costume
yeah so they they got married in Cancun
that's Wow you may even love ya then now
like so in the beginning it was really
rough with the friend right with Amanda
but then now they actually like travel
together I think she looks so old the
Sun maybe maybe just the because of
stress
ah maybe stress your product of the
environment you also start like meshing
and blending oh you know what's
happening he's studying the life force
out of her he's actually getting younger
that's how he stay so young as he gets
women every time they kissed you see
essence come out yeah but knock dude I
haven't heard of that [ __ ] in ages
it's [ __ ] mouth ray that's even
before Dumb and Dumber you know that
thing he would spray in his mouth and it
would go that way I'm not good I don't
even know what does it taste so good I
bet they just drink you breath mints and
[ __ ] you don't need but not y'all
remember [ __ ] Listerine patches yeah
that [ __ ] was like eating a square of
acid enjoyed the taste of it I like it
should've been in it but what about like
Mac now back then yeah old terms then
back down back down bring it back that
[ __ ] right there was red day get my dad
used to have them all the time and I
remember I took one from him I ate it
and that [ __ ] made me cry cause it hurt
so bad you're not supposed to eat it
though you're supposed to just melt on
your
No exactly it burned oh I see like a
[ __ ] it hurts like I don't
understand why people like it had a
friend I would have liked she would
finish a pack like it would they like
two times because she would have so many
sheets I was impressed things so bad I
don't think it was I think she just
liked it so much so she will just eat a
[ __ ] ton at a time [ __ ] nasty [ __ ]
brush your teeth this story reminds me
of like childhood dreams but all [ __ ]
up because you know like when you're
really close with someone you wish you
were family and you're like what if you
[ __ ] bury my sister and then we could
be like brothers or something right so
they can now be like mother and daughter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]